been talking so much about the state of
our schools we've heard from Educators
lawmakers parents but what about the
students themselves here's a chance
that's the goal of a local video contest
joining me now Jana wilcoxlavin the CEO
of opportunity 180 and you're talking
about this video contest for kids I
stand with kids and it's student-led
tell me about first of all before we
jump into the contest opportunity 180
what is it yeah for those who don't know
because you guys started in 2015. we did
and what's the basis yeah so our goal is
to make sure that every kid graduates
high school College and Career ready and
prepared to live whatever life they
dream so we do that lots of ways we try
to elevate student voice we invest in
Talent Development and supporting future
education leaders we Advocate at the
legislature for student-centered
policies and so we really try to ensure
that the entire Community is focused on
putting kids first making sure that
every kid is prepared for the future and
so really by elevating their voice
you're now offering this is the second
year for this I stand
um this video contest so tell me first
of all how did it come about and and
what's the real purpose behind it what's
the driving force yeah the driving force
is how do we get more kids to elevate
their voices and share with us what's
happening the best ideas tend to come
from the users right so when we have
questions about what should we should be
doing in education often asking those
who are in the seats really helps us
come up with better ideas and better
strategies and there aren't a lot of
great ways for kids to have their voices
heard you know they're in school most of
the time they're not able to testify
it's challenging to find ways to elevate
your voice and so we thought a video
contest where kids could tell us what
they want to be true be creative share
their story and then offer prizes that
they could use as scholarships or to
support whatever it is that would help
them prepare for their future so these
videos need to be about two minutes long
two minutes what are you looking for and
these are all aged from Little to high
school two minutes best creative
whatever it is that you want of your
school but then what else can make them
stand out so that they can win the the
prize money gift card yeah so it'll be
third through 12th grade okay and we're
really looking for
um students that are you know have a
good idea clear on their idea we're not
going to look at video production
quality because we really want it to not
be about what sort of equipment you have
available you want it to be the thumb
for me okay got it um so we encourage
kids to be creative stick to the
question you know answer directly stay
within the time and really share their
their personal story so the more we can
hear directly about what matters to each
kid makes a difference now you this is
the second year so last year what were
some of the themes what did what did
kids want what do they want change yeah
so kids talked a lot about
um you know they love having teachers
who care about them and who are focused
on them and hold them to high
expectations which is great I heard a
lot about safety okay um which is the
theme we hear about a lot yeah we heard
some about food
and kids wanting to to be in charge of
lunch
um but you know I think the more we can
offer kids a chance to say what they
want to be in charge of and allow them
to think outside the box about what
could be possible in their school just
the better we'll all be as a community
yeah and the world is their oyster Jana
thank you so much for coming on the show
today we're going to post all this
information on our website so you can
get the details if your kiddos want to
make one of these videos we certainly
encourage that because there's prize
money to be had like 500 right 500 for
the first prize in each grade band okay
so it'll be on our website we're going
to have all that thank you again for
joining us here early this morning stick
around we're gonna have more good day
after the break